[Applaudissements]
bon ça c'est pour après d'abord je suis
venu vous parler de ces petits objets et
plus particulièrement ce petit objet
c'est difficile à distinguer à cette
distance
et pourtant en 2017 on en a produit 22
milliards c'est à dire que si on les met
bout à bout les uns derrière les autres
on peut faire 35 fois le tour de la
terre avec 35 fois il y en a par exemple
une dans votre bac 2
il y en a six dans votre ordinateur
portable une dizaine dans un aspirateur
sans fil il y en a 30 danse vélos
électriques et y en a plus de 8000 dans
une voiture électrique tesla
donc c'est une pile mais plus
particulièrement c'est une cellules
lithium-ion
vous avez dû en entendre parler déjà et
ce qui est incroyable en fait vraiment
une nouveauté pour moi en tout cas c'est
que c'est la même cellule même modèle
tout dans tous ses appareils même même
champ même chimie même tension même
forme exacte même dimension donc tous
ces appareils c'est la même et en fait
c'est possible grâce à un principe
physique relativement simple si je
prends une deuxième cellule et que je
mets le moins de la première avec le
plus de l'autre en fait je double la
puissance et si je mets le plus avec le
plus je double l'autonomie est ainsi en
choisissant bien la disposition de plein
de cellules on peut répondre à n'importe
quel besoin en énergie je ne sais pas
pour vous mais moi ça c'est déjà une
découverte en fait parce que en fait on
vit dans un monde d'incompatibilité par
exemple combien de télécommande se
trouve à côté de votre téléviseur ou
alors quand vous allez dans un dans un
magasin et que vous achetez un nouvel
appareil
vous allez dans le magasin vous achetez
vous demandez pas au vendeur
si vous pouvez utiliser le chargeur de
l'ancien avec le nouveau évidemment
c'est incompatible
et pourtant en fait derrière cette
espèce de complexité de façade se cache
les mêmes petit cylindre et moi j'ai
découvert ça en faisant en faisant ce
vélo c'est à dire que j'ai eu jean
certaine nostalgie pour les formes des
années 60 donc ça c'est une mobylette
des années 60 et j'ai voulu à
transformer en un vélo électrique parce
que en fait avec un vélo électrique vous
n'avez pas besoin de carte grise de
plaques d'assurance de casque surtout ça
fait pas de pollution et pas de bruit
est donc bon j'ai passé un peu de temps
ça se fait pas comme ça et surtout le
problème c'est que je voulais garder
l'esthétique et donc j'ai mis la
batterie là dedans et pour qu'elles
soient suffisamment gros j'ai dû
fabriquer une batterie et quand j'ai
fabriqué une batterie j'ai découvert ces
petits cylindres à ces cellules
lithium-ion et je vous avoue ça a tout
de suite était une découverte et une
passion enfin je suis devenu fou avec
parce que en fait ça c'est de l'énergie
en var c'est de l'énergie en bas on n'a
jamais mis autant d'énergie dans un
objet aussi petit et aussi puissant le
la différence avec une cellule bénigne
piles par une pile alcaline que vous
trouvez dans un supermarché c'est que
ces cellules qui avions contiennent des
métaux rares et les métaux rares par
exemple le cobalt comme leurs noms
l'indiquent on trouve très peu sur terre
par exemple le cobalt il est fabriqué
dans des supernovas c'est à dire des
étoiles il ya que sur certaines
astéroïde qui en a en grande quantité il
ya même des gens qui réfléchissent à
capturer ces astéroïdes pour les amener
sur terre parce que ça coûte
relativement cher comme matière et d'eau
et donc
un oui et en fait ça quand on y
réfléchit non mais parce que ça me
perturbe vachement en fait cessé
et d'autres quand on y réfléchit ça veut
dire que les véhicules là qu'on voit
dans la rue les tesla et autres en fait
ça roule avec de la poudre des toiles et
c'est aussi avec de la poudre des toits
de la poussière des toiles que sont
fabriqués toutes les technologies là qui
doivent nous sauver du réchauffement
climatique et ouais est en fait aussi ce
qui si on se rend compte si on cherche
un peu
salah les cellules lithium ion couplé
avec des panneaux solaires c'est
actuellement la meilleure façon
d'apporter l'électricité dans les pays
les plus pauvres et les moins développés
et donc si on se met pas ce qu'il ya un
milliard de personnes en fait qu'à pas
l'électricité sur terre et donc si on se
met si on fait l'exercice de se mettre
avec eux on se rend compte que sans
l'électricité
en fait c'est la peur et l'ennui
pourquoi parce que le soir déjà sa tombe
relativement tôt comme par exemple
maintenant donc a pas de lecture parce
que pas de lumière ya pas de soirée avec
des amis il n'ya pas de cinéma mais
aussi a pas de moyen de communication
n'y a pas de téléphone portable n'ya pas
d'internet donc globalement si on
réfléchit bien on enlève beaucoup de
choses de notre vie d'occidentaux et
c'est vraiment la peur et l'ennui et et
en fait ça je vous dis ça parce que en
fait l'énergie c'est à la base de notre
civilisation
et d'ailleurs ça se vérifie depuis
toujours parce que l'ict l'histoire
qu'elles soient politiques économiques
et par conséquent social et
environnemental
elle est dictée par l'énergie par
exemple si vous vous rappelez de la
première révolution industrielle
c'est à dire en fait la première
révolution énergétique vous avez les
machines à vapeur qui entraîne des
locomotives ou des métiers à tisser et
en fait on se rend compte que tout la
géopolitique du 19e siècle et va se
résumer en fait et elle va s'articuler
autour d'une matière le charbon qui va
être dominée par un pays l'angleterre et
20e siècles ce qui est intéressant c'est
que c'est exactement le même schéma
vous avez les frères wright qui font
décoller le premier avion avec un moteur
à explosion
les usines ford produisent des véhicules
à la chaîne et toute la géopolitique du
siècle les conflits les frontières tout
s'explique en grande partie par une
matière le pétrole qui est dominé par un
pays les états unis
hélas ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
est au tout début du 21e siècle
et vous avez ces petits bâtonnets
d'énergie là c'est cette fin ce truc là
que j'aime beaucoup et en fait vous
rendez compte qu'il ya une matière à
part peut-être parce qu'on est au tout
début du siècle tout tout reste à écrire
mais vous avez une matière cette poudre
étoiles ces métaux rares qui est dominé
par un pays la chine
et oui parce que la chine détient 90% de
la production mondiale des métaux rares
comme le cobalt le nickel et autres et
dès lors on comprend beaucoup mieux
pourquoi elle pousse les énergies
renouvelables elle signe la coop 21 à la
différence de donald trump qui lui veut
rester dans l'ancien monde celui du
pétrole donc vraiment j'attire votre
attention là sur ces petits cylindres
parce que cette nouvelle dépendance elle
vient pas sans conséquence humains que
nous sommes quand il y en aura plus de
ces trucs là il en faudra encore faudra
en produire toujours plus et donc dans
ces cas-là on connaît deux méthodes
la première c'est faire la guerre
classique
la deuxième s'est fracassé la terre là
pour lui faire recracher vraiment
jusqu'au dernier atome de métaux rares
et est donc et donc oui il faut que je
clique désolé
voilà donc maintenant qu'est le premier
ce live y en a pas beaucoup il y en a
que deux donc ça va aller maintenant il
ya le premier slide pouvait repérer le
22 mille milliards de cellules dont je
vous parlais au début à de production
sas et la production en fait de chaque
année de cellules lithium-ion sur terre
ce qui est marrant c'est de voir le 65
milliards là qui arrive de 2020 et donc
si vous regardez bien là cette courbe
moi moi j'y vois une vague en fait je
vois vraiment quelque chose là comme ça
une belle vague qui arrive parce que
nous on est là on est en dehors on est
on est en fait on est on est avant la
vague moi je vois vraiment une vague
parce qu'en fait il ya il va bien une
vague immense et qui est à 5 10 années
de nos côtes et 5 10 années en fait
c'est la durée de vie de ces cellules
lithium-ion nos côtes évidemment ces
poubelles c'est nos poubelles
donc la vraie question qui se pose
maintenant c'est de savoir cette vague
là comment comment la surf en fait parce
que on va pas faire un discours
alarmiste on va essayer de faire un truc
qui fonctionne et donc ok je suis
d'accord il ya des gens qui gloussent un
peu parce qu'effectivement le surf là
c'est pas un truc évident pour les gens
qui habitent dans la région et qui
pratique enfin en tout cas moi je trouve
ça vraiment ingrat et donc pour les
trucs ingrat j utilise une méthode que
j'appelle la méthode d une heure par
jour
c'est hyper simple mais moi je trouve ça
super puissant la méthode d une heure
par jour ça ne consiste à vous fixer une
mission donc ça peut être par exemple
apprendre le japonais et une fois que
vous avez votre mission vous signé un
pacte avec vous même qui stipule que
vous allez passer une heure par jour
consacrées à cette mission et ça quelles
que soient les conditions par exemple
que vous ayez mal à la tête
qu'ils soient trois heures du matin que
soit votre anniversaire une heure par
jour et si vous tenez le coup
franchement y'a rien qui résiste donc
moi je suis suffisamment bizarre pour
appliquer cette méthode là à à ces
cellules lithium-ion et donc j'ai
commencé par le basique c'est à dire que
je me suis renseigné sur le recyclage de
ces cellules lithium-ion en france donc
je me suis rendu compte qu'on en deux
mots en fait on récupère 50 % de ces
cellules est ensuite le pr la procédure
ça consiste à les chauffer à 150 degrés
pour enlever les plastiques et autres
ensuite elle est broyé
elle est amusé à les chauffer à 900
degrés puis ensuite elle est baignée
dans des bains d'acide pour essayer de
séparer les différents matériaux donc
d'un point de vue environnemental
je suis pas de dessin et et d'un point
de vue économique en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça nous coûte
hyper cher ça coûte 4000 euros la tonne
à détruire comme ça et donc les
conditions de surf moyens quoi donc en
fait je suis allé plus loin parce que là
mais de la vraie puissance de cette
fameuse méthode d une heure par jour
c'est que pendant les 23 autres heures
de la journée
en fait votre cerveau il travaille pour
vous il est tout le temps guidé par
cette espèce de tache sous jacente est
donc pour l'anecdote j'étais en train de
regarder un film sur le dernier empereur
de chine
mais rien à voir avec les maîtres des
métaux rares est en mai dernier empereur
de chine
on y voit des des médecins qui ausculte
des espèces de paniers en osier et
dedans il ya les excréments du souverain
enfin du de l'empereur et tous les jours
il regarde ici l'ironie fils et c'est
mon igloo de presse qu on n'en est pas
là mais c'est pas loin et en fait là mon
cerveau hills a dit mais oui bien sûr en
fait la vérité se cache là où ça pue et
donc
et donc les prochaines les heures
suivantes en fait les est consacrée à
faire les poubelles et oui et donc j'ai
retrouvé en fait le maximum de batteries
lithium-ion que je pouvais retrouver
dans différentes poubelles et l'étape
suivante ça a été de les ouvrir pour
extraire ces fameuses cellules et on
recensait déjà je me suis rendu compte
d'une chose c'est à dire que ces
cellules avec leur disposition en série
ou en parallèle avec les plus et les
plus et les moins et moins comme je vous
disais au début mais en fait c'est la
loi du maillon faible qui s'applique
quand il y en a une qui tombe en panne
en fait c'est toute la batterie qui part
à la poubelle et alors donc j'ai
continué et j'ai mesuré en fait la
capacité c'est-à-dire l'état de santé de
chacune des cellules que je trouvais
dans la poubelle
j'en ai fait des centaines et des
centaines et des centaines et des
caisses n'en est en fait c'est pour ça
que je vais vous parler aujourd'hui
c'est parce qu'avec ça j'ai fait une
découverte en notant vraiment tout en
faisant de la data on va dire là dessus
et qui se résume en un seul chiffre et
se siffler ses 72 %
en fait il ya 72 % des cellules qu'on
trouve dans la poubelle
max en parfait état de fonctionnement
donc moi j'ai trouvé ça hyper
intéressant et je suis allé voir
je suis allé voir je suis allé voir des
spécialistes et les spécialistes range
franchement eux ils n'ont pas trouvé ça
intéressant je pense qu'ils n'aiment pas
du tout le surf et où c'était un vide
mais total quoi parce qu'ils m'ont dit
en fait t'es mignon mais elle est
cellules lithium-ion qui sont un
poubelle nous on s'en fout parce que
neuf ça vaut pas assez cher pour qu'on
se soucie des anciennes même si elle
marche et tout c'est super mais c'est
pas assez cher pour que ce soit et donc
sert que malgré tout ce que je vous ai
raconté malgré que ce soit de la
poudrière de la poule rodez toile malgré
que le fait malgré le fait qu'ils et des
milliards de gens qui est pas
l'électricité
mais on jette des trucs qui ne
fonctionne parfaitement et en plus on
dépense une fortune pour les détruire
et ça en fait on m'a expliqué que ça
s'appelait la loi du marché et cette loi
cette loi du marché mois quand moi je la
trouve assez récurrente et et en fait ça
me fait penser quand on parle de ça a
une image de mon enfance parce que mes
grands parents étaient agriculteurs et
il avait une oeuvre d'art dans la ferme
c'était celle-là c'est l'angélus de
millet et eux il avait ça dans l'eure
dans leur ferme parce que cette oeuvre
d'art elle symbolisait pour eux toute la
majesté des gens qui en fait chaque jour
cultivent la terre parce que quand ils
cultivent la terre en fait c'est des
gens qui payent la taxe
et quand je parle d'une taxe est pas une
taxe pécuniaire
c'est une taxe c'est une démarche en
fait cette démarche là c'est juste de
cons c'est une démarche qu'on doit à la
terre et cette démarche c'est juste de
se baisser pour ramasser ce qu'elle nous
donne s'est passé pas plus cher que ça
est en fête la terre tourne parce que on
paye tous cette taxe
la plupart d'entre nous en tout cas
payons cette taxe et quand un système
commença à plus faire ça en fait on
commence à vivre à crédit sur la terre
et moi je trouve ça franchement je
trouve ça inacceptable parce que si on y
réfléchit
cette loi du marché en fait c'est une
mascarade
c'est basé sur notre croyance parce que
par exemple si on y réfléchit je prends
j'en ai pas désolé mais si je prends un
billet de 50 euros et que enfin vous
êtes d'accord c'est un bout de papier
et pourtant ce bout de papier je peux
l'échanger contre dira m 2000 bout de
papier
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya bien un pacte
qui lie les deux c'est à dire qu'il ya
bien un fou un moment qui a fait un
exposé d'acte fondateur d'échanger un
bout de papier contre de l'or
donc en fait ce que ça veut dire ça ça
veut dire que c'est nous qui définissons
la valeur des choses c'est nous qui
définissons la valeur de ces cellules et
donc moi j'imagine un monde où en fait
quand vous avez tout simplement une
batterie qui tombe en panne vous pouvez
la signaler et quelqu'un vient la
chercher il ouvrit sort les cellules il
fait le tri et comme elles marchent
encore il peut refaire des batteries
avec puisque et tout et tout est fait à
partir de cette brique universel donc il
refait des batteries avec qui les revend
mêmes vous toucher de l'argent pourquoi
pas ça veut dire que vous devenez
actionnaires en fait à dire que c'est
comme un actionnaire sauf que c'est vos
déchets qui vous file des dividendes
mais moi je moi moi c'est moi j'y crois
à fond et en fait j'y crois tellement
que à partir de maintenant je vous
rachète toutes vos batteries non mais je
suis sérieux vous avez je suis ni faire
sérieux à partir de maintenant vous
pouvez essayer enfin vous pouvez pas
vous devez me vendre vos batteries voilà
merci beaucoup
dans paramètres